ja meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
liebe mitbürgern mitbürger deshalb keine
normale ministerin konferenz über sie
die letzten vier fünf monate hatten wo
wir stundenlang geredet haben über
kleine details
heute ist die lage anders denn corona
ist außer kontrolle geraten
die lage ist eigentlich wieder fünf vor
zwölf deswegen wollen wir keine halben
sachen mehr machen sondern konsequent
handeln wir hatten letzte woche in
bayern den katastrophenfall ausgerufen
und ein journalist fragte mich ist das
nicht übertrieben
unabhängig davon dass es dann sehr viele
praktische fragen geht corona ist eine
katastrophe corona ist eine katastrophe
die unser leben mehr betrifft als jede
krise die wir den letzten 50 jahren
zuvor haben
das sind braucht es jetzt auch eine
kraftanstrengung von uns allen eine
nationale kraftanstrengung ganz oder gar
nicht heißt das motto nicht mehr halt
hat sich ein bisschen oder versuchen
ausnahmen und schlupflöcher zu suchen
sondern konsequent entscheiden
der lock down leicht wie wir ihn
versucht haben hatte eine wirkung er war
eine medizin aber sie hat nicht gereicht
wir waren nicht mit der notwendigen
therapie konsequenz dabei wenn wir nicht
aufpassen wird deutschland schnell das
sorgenkind in ganz europa deswegen
mussten und müssen die handeln
besonders schlimm und besorgt macht uns
doch alle von die zahl der todesfälle
alle drei minuten stirbt jemand in
deutschland an corona es wird wohl die
häufigste todesursache in diesem jahr
werden
das sind können wir darauf nicht
achselzuckend reagieren oder das als
statistische größe wahrnehmen wieder all
den stecken familien menschen die auch
gerne weihnachten silvester erlebt
hätten die kliniken echt sind die echten
derzeit unter der belastung teilweise
gibt es schon triage in deutschland
nämlich dass man entscheidet wer
behandelt wird oder wer woanders sind
verlegt werden muss wir reden manchmal
über ferien und einzel details oder was
einkaufen
dabei kämpfen pflegerinnen und pfleger
und ärzte jeden tag eine schier
unermüdlichen kampf bergamo ist näher
als der ein oder andere glaubt um das zu
verhindern müssen wir konsequent handeln
wir sind nicht herzlos genau das
gegenteil ist der fall
mich persönlich und wir uns alle rührte
und deswegen dürfen wir aus
bequemlichkeit oder einen monetären
interessen keine fehlentscheidungen
treffen denn eines lehrt uns überall
kronen der welt je länger man je später
man handelt desto länger dauert es und
desto größer sind die schädigung für
gesundheit und wirtschaft das positive
heute ist wir haben alle miteinander
klar und konsequent uns auf einen
beschluss geeinigt kein sowohl-als-auch
sondern eine richtung ist eine bittere
pille aber ich glaube diese dosis ist
jetzt richtig dass wichtiges wir machen
nicht wieder eine diskussion über
ausnahmen sondern über konsequentes
umsetzen
sind wir ehrlich seit monaten haben uns
die diskussion über ausnahmen und
details und das letzte haar in der suppe
letztlich auch die akzeptanz vieler
dieser gemeinsamen ideen geschwächt und
untergraben
deswegen ist wichtig ab mittwoch richtig
lockdown in deutschland für alle
konsequent und auch klar verständlich
und anwendbar geplant bis 10 januar ich
sage ausdrücklich so lange es dauert
krone hält sich nicht an daten der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz krone hält
sich nicht an feiertage corona nimmt den
freiraum dem beben lässt und deswegen
muss unsere oberste aufgaben priorität
jetzt das virus zu bekämpfen
es hat überhaupt keinen sinn über in der
welt gibt es zweite und dritte wellen
sogar übrigens in der geschichte war
immer die zweite oder dritte welle am
gefährlichsten haben die zweite warum
weil man es unterschätzt hat das ist
auch heute wichtig noch einmal klar zu
machen dass wir in einer sehr ernsten
situation sagt es ist zeit für
gemeinsamkeit wir alle sitzen in
deutschland im gleichen boot
alle müssen mitmachen deswegen aus
meiner sicht war das heute sehr sehr
wichtig die gute vorbereitung die klare
führung auch durch die kanzlerin wenn
ich das sagen darf und auch dass alle
mitgemacht haben wir bayern sind
besonders getroffen wir haben heute
erstmals den incidents wert über 200 für
das ganze land überschritten
das heißt wenn man das ausland sieht
sind wir ein hotspot aber es ist anders
als bislang gedacht in den letzten
war die tendenz es wird im norden
weniger und im süden
hoffentlich auch ein bisschen weniger
ist jetzt umgekehrt von süd nach nord
wanders über alles geht ganz schnell
es ist auch keine frage von besser oder
schlechter sondern nur von gemeinsam und
gleich betroffen wie wir agieren müssen
für bayern kann ich sagen wir werden die
beschlüsse maximal umsetzen wir haben in
der letzten woche bereits ja maßnahmen
vor getroffen die alle in diese richtung
gehen und bin sehr dankbar dass wir
diesen weg gemeinsam gehen können was
heißt jetzt komplett lockdown alle
geschäfte zu ab mittwoch es gab in einer
anderen der dass auch er hätte gern
machen müssen es lag aber nicht daran
dass wir jetzt mittwoch haben weil weil
ein ministerpräsident nicht wollte
sondern weil es klare
parlamentsbeteiligung und gibt die dazu
zwingen fristen einzuhalten deswegen am
mittwoch das ist insofern auch dann ein
besonderes vorgehen weil wir damit auch
uns an die eigenen gesetze halten die
vorgegeben
es gibt dafür eine umfangreiche
entschädigung des bundes auch dafür
schon mal ein herzliches dankeschön in
den innenstädten also alles runter bis
auf die geschäfte sage mal dass
lebensmittel und das wirklich
notwendigsten alltäglichen bedarfs
denn die philosophie heißt daheim
bleiben die philosophie heißt kontakte
vermeiden
die philosophie heißt nicht irgendwo
sein sondern am besten zu hause mit der
familie deswegen übrigens auch in den
innenstädten nicht nur geschäfte zu
sondern auch ein klares alkoholverbot um
glühwein to go und lieber ein hopping zu
verhindern
zweiter ab mittwoch für bayerns
eigentlich dass alle schulen und alle
kitas komplett zu eine klare regelung
es ist so dass vor weihnachten damit wir
kein risiko eingehen wir wollen studien
zeigen zu nehmen dass auch kinder auch
kleinstkinder betroffen sein können
meist ohne jedes symptom aber dafür umso
leichter die möglichkeit der ansteckung
weil wenn kein symptom ist neigt man
vielleicht eher zum sozialverhalten
darauf weniger rücksicht nehmen zu
können die kleinen nehmen wir auch
besonders gerne in den armen
dieses bei 17 18 jährigen sicherlich
etwas anders
neue studien usa oder österreich zeigen
dass dort ein erhöhtes risiko ist
deswegen vor weihnachten auf nummer
sicher gehen und wenn dann richtig und
nicht wieder ihr da
oder damit deswegen ab mittwoch alles zu
alle jahrgangsstufen und feiern mit
distanz unterricht ja mit notbetreuung
das gilt für schule und kita
dort wo es notwendig ist für die eltern
mit ausgleich eltern können auch ein
ausgleich nehmen wenn es keine
möglichkeit der betreuung gibt und sie
deswegen urlaub nehmen müssen dann soll
es einen finanziellen ausgleich geben
und appell an die arbeitgeber ist glaube
ich sowieso wichtig sowohl über
weihnachten neujahr möglichst viel
betriebsferien zu machen und homeoffice
anzubieten wo es nur geht
diese maßnahmen gelten alle auch in der
schule
bis 10 januar wir in bayern haben den
vorteil dass wir zu vier länder gehören
die ohnehin bis 10 4 januar zu haben es
gibt uns zeit aber auch danach kann ich
mir nicht vorstellen dass einfach alles
wieder so normal weitergeht worauf wir
allerdings besonders achten dass
abschlussklassen ihre prüfungen schaffen
werden darauf wird geachtet entweder
durch das verschieben der
prüfungstermine wir holen das so nach
ohne zusätzliche leistungsdruck die
schülern schülern eltern sollen sich
darauf verlassen können wenn man alles
tun dass die gleiche bildungsqualität
erhalten bleibt ohne ein zusätzliches
stressabbau oder eine stress mittlere
abschlüsse zu haben zu dem privaten
kontakten
da bleibt es zunächst mal bei den
bisherigen regelungen für uns in bayern
ist das eine klare ausgangs beschränkung
ist gibt das haus nur aus triftigen
grund zu verlassen
wir haben in bayern schon in den
bisherigen über 200 ausgangssperren
gemacht von 21 uhr bis 510 den letzten
tagen sehr bewährt wir halten daran fest
und wir werden nach dem bayern jetzt
überall im ganzen land 200 hat werden
wir das jetzt für ganz bayern machen
warum wir wollen auch da die ganzen
privaten feiern private kontakte einfach
reduzieren
ich weiß das ist nicht einfach und es
ist gerade für die jungen leute
unglaublich nervig und stressig aber
jetzt lieber für die nächsten wochen
wieder zusammen halten als das ganze
eine endlosschleife zu haben es hilft
uns nichts wir müssen ganz besonders an
die älteren denken und zu eltern und
großeltern sie zu schützen ist gebot für
uns alle bei weihnachten gibt es eine
verbesserte regierung die kanzler hat es
schon gesagt dort wird es besonders
schwierig seien auch die gottesdienste
ja für viele ist das eine große
einschränkung dass gottesdienste nur mit
maske
mit anmeldung um abstände zu halten und
ohne gesamt stattfinden soll
aber trat in der kirche geht es um das
leben der menschen in schutz der
menschen
wir sind glaube ich ist es gut
vertretbar an silvester die klare
regelung dort wo ausgangssperren sind
gilt es auch übrigens dann ist ab 21 uhr
das ist bei uns dann in bayern so bleibt
man ohnehin zu hause
da gilt auch die gesamten anderen regeln
wir haben uns heute noch einmal darauf
verständigt die faktor bilderverbot zu
haben warum jetzt die faktoren bella
vattrodt hatten das böllern irgendeine
auswirkung pandemisch zunächst auf den
ersten blick nicht wir haben aber aus
den krankenhäusern den dringenden wunsch
bekommen den dringenden wunsch dass wenn
die normalen verletzungen die es jedes
jahr böller gibt dazu kommen sind die
krankenhäuser nicht mehr aufnahmefähig
deswegen diesem jahr eine ausnahme
das heißt es wird halt ein stilles
silvester es ist schade es ist wirklich
schade aber es ist glaube ich in diesem
jahr geboten
bei alten und pflegeheimen ist uns der
schutz der älteren ganz besonders hat
sich übrigens gezeigt obwohl seit
monaten alle länder und kommunen
entsprechende schutzmaßnahmen treffen
ist krone reingekommen
übrigens nicht nur durch besucher
sondern lange eben auch durch durch
mitarbeiter mitarbeiter
dies haben in den grenzregionen übrigens
auch gespürt dass dort einträge möglich
sind es hat letzte woche ziehen
fernsehsender auch das
max-planck-institut übrigens noch mal de
facto mit bestätigt haben wir klare
regeln besucher nur einmal pro tag mit
maske mit test test pflicht für
mitarbeiter mindestens zweimal die woche
und das sage er zu bayern wo es nur geht
auch vorhandene andere einrichtungen zu
nutzen um eine entsprechende verlegung
zu machen
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
das sind jetzt klare regeln
ich glaube dass sie auch weil sie für
alle sind und ohne große ausnahmen sind
verständlicher und besser kommuniziert
mit machbar sind wir haben in den
vergangenen monaten in der regel werke
die selbst da eine andere minister wenn
er gefragt vor dem fernsehen
erst mal nachschauen musste aber sie
alle parat hatte das kann man jetzt
glaube ich ganz gut verstehen
für manche ist es eine große
einschränkung enttäuschung
ich bin sicher dass es für die mehrzahl
aber
eine gewisse erleichterung ist weil sie
froh darüber sind dass wir jetzt alle
den einheitlichen weg gehen
es fällt uns nicht leicht es zu tun
betont ist nicht wie manche der
querdenker gruppen meinen aus einem
politischen motiv im sinne des wortes
freude machen betont ist nicht weil wir
es wollen sondern weil wir es müssen und
zwar aus echter verantwortung für die
menschen führen zu eltern und großeltern
und für das ganze land
es gibt hoffnung natürlich auch in
dieser schweren zeit die maßnahmen jetzt
den hoffnung bei ihr fest überzeugt sind
sie können wirken wenn alle mitmachen
wir kommen da auch durch als deutschland
wir überstehen das auch die frage ist
nur mit welchen schäden und wir wollen
sie so klein wie möglich halten
der impfstoff ist eine hoffnung ja auch
wenn das sicherlich nicht über nacht
geht erst der anzeigen sind ja da das
nicht alles an impfstoff zur verfügung
steht wie gewünscht das heißt sie müssen
sehr klug überlegen wie wir trotzdem
konsequent impfung könne die logistische
infrastruktur in den ländern steht in
bayern fast 100 zentren über 2000 ärzte
die bereit sind hat mich selber davon
nicht überzeugt jetzt sparen wir uns die
woche da und es läuft sehr gut aber erst
muss der impfstoff phasen da muss noch
mal klasse entweder alles gemacht werden
kann
das wird noch gar nicht einfach werden
ich sage ihnen aber auch meine
hauptsorge ist nicht das am impfstoff am
anzug zu wenig ist sondern dass am ende
sich nicht genügend werden es wird nicht
reichen nur die wollen arabien gruppen
zu impfen
nur die risikogruppen nur die kritische
infrastruktur sondern es müssen alle
auch beim impfen mitmachen denn sonst
wird ist ein ständiges hin und her auf
und ab und das ist doch die perspektive
die wir brauchen
irgendwann einmal den großen wurf zu
machen so dass wir mit möglichst viel
schutz durch impfung und niedrigsten
zahlen die wir haben auch deswegen
übrigens fürs impfen brauchen wir
niedrige zahlen keine und zahlen das zu
schaffen
insofern schließe mich noch bei dem
appell an
es kommt jetzt auch wirklich jeden
einzelnen an keiner steht außen vor
bitte ganz herzlich mitzumachen es ist
eine schwierige zeit
aber vielleicht ist die sogenannte
startet zeit bei uns in bayern wenn man
sagt zwischen weihnachten neujahr die
jetzt sozusagen früher beginnt und
länger dauert ist vielleicht die beste
gelegenheit daheim zu bleiben und ein
ist noch mein letzter satz zu besinnen
das wichtigste geschenk an weihnachten
ist nicht das teuerste sondern ist die
zeit die gemeinsam verbracht werden kann
in der familie und auch das sollte man
dieses jahr vielleicht mal viel stärker
als je wieder bewerten und bis in mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren